[Musik]
mit
red
[Musik]
hallo
heute ist einen flug ab/bis und vor
allem sehr leckeres rezept ich werde
nämlich clarity machen und zwar eine
abwehr passte keine große sondern diese
kleinen wesen handlichen geräten zu
unterwegs für unterwegs oder ob sie
passivrauch genau also finde es ist ein
super picknick rezept also familia wird
sich in dieser etwas täten verlieben
sie will nämlich immer mit uns
picknicken jetzt bei dem schönen wetter
draußen passt hervorragend die erste
zeit ist da das heißt stelle ich in der
küche macht diese kleinen preis ich habe
einmal die version wie so eine kleine
clique also ein doppeldecker kickt und
am stiel das heißt man kann diese
mitnehmen und muss sich nicht die hände
schmutzig machen und kann sie einfach
euren verknappung sicher auch unterwegs
die liebesbotschaft man kann ja auch zum
beispiel und logos strauß draus machen
morath kopf gebissen die dinge die du
nie wo wir bekommen wird hier aber das
okay zum fix und fertig ich sage es mal
so ich den beitrag gemacht habe und bei
den formalitäten für den teig brauche
ich 450 vom 25 zucker einen teelöffel
salz 30 vom kokosöl 225 eiskalte mutter
habe ich 60 milliliter eiskalte wasser
und zwei teelöffel es ist bereits so und
dafür nämlich etwas mehl geht am besten
mit einem mixer freund der comics habt
könnt ihr zum beispiel auch so einen
zeigte hacker nehmen da geht's auch ganz
gut beim freitag ist nämlich ganz
wichtig dass der teig nicht warum jetzt
weil sie den ich hab kündeten messer
nehmen und dann zeigt erst mal so sagen
bevor die hände dran gehen
als nächstes kommen salz und zucker dazu
und den feiertag habe ich auch schon mal
zubereitet und zwar bei den linien tage
waren auch zu verlängern
damit kommt die kalte butter mit rein
habe ich bereits in stücke geschnitten
und wir dann einfach ein bisschen
gelagert auch ganz kurz nur passieren
lassen und dabei die mutter nur noch in
kleinen stücken zu sehen ist jetzt noch
ins kalte wasser und der explosion gibt
auch nur noch ganz ernst was verboten
heraus und formen jetzt mit den händen
ganz schnell zu einem festen teig
zusammen und hiermit jetzt einfach drauf
achten dass der teig nicht warm wird
[Musik]
flach und geht ihnen in so eine schale
mit den ab und stellen dann für
mindestens zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank
derzeit ist bereit und ich werde zumal
die füllung zubereiten bei mir gibt's
heute eine richtig leckere erfüllung als
erster zeit ist sag ich mal die zutaten
für die füllung traurig 300 gramm
erdbeeren brauchen 50 bis 80 weitere
stärke etwas sonne sechs fragt und einem
teelöffel wetten dass wir jetzt mal die
erste anbieter bereit gewaschen und die
was jemand vorher nämlich das grün hier
oben weg
[Musik]
jetzt werden sie fein gewürfelt dafür
zahle ich die etwa jetzt ein bis zwei
mal durch und gibt ihnen in den schafen
ali da habe ich jetzt den alligator
genommen sein bruder freut sich daher
vor allem schweinegrippe etwas
[Musik]
die fn in einem topf die welt uns
eingekauft einfach heute später gekommen
so viel flüssigkeit verlieren würden im
ofen deswegen wir dazu noch flüssigkeit
weggenommen
da gebe ich stärke und zucker dazu mit
nehmt ihr einfach zu viel zucker achtet
darauf dass die füllung gesüßt genug ist
denn der freitag ist es nicht sich
selbst er sei trat deswegen sollte die
fünf eigentlich geschmack natürlich auch
angemessen sagt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bildschön verrührt und dann kann ich das
so etwas zwei bis drei minuten lang
einkochen
die erfüllung bereits nicht viel wert
und damit sie abkühlen kann und sobald
er zeigt dann auch kommen dadurch es
geht gleich mit dem juni-wert weiter
der teig ist es gut durch gekühlt und
jetzt werde ich ihnen einmal kräftig
treten wo wir dann bis ein geschmeidiger
ist aber wirklich schön kalt arbeite ich
auch natürlich hohem masse weil ich da
einfach ein wenig mehr brauchen und wenn
es den teig auf 3 mm stärke autoren und
halb so viel für nehme ich mir diese
zweite holzer
[Musik]
und es sind ja einen ausbrecher nach mal
ich will mit so einer privaten
aufsteiger und der sechs zentimeter im
durchmesser
[Musik]
es werden die länder erst mit wasser
verstrichen verbleibende teil gleich
besser aneinander kleben
bei der zweiten hälfte nämlich jetzt
einen webauftritt super süß aus und
stechen heraus nicht ganz so wild wenn
dieses ausgestopften herz gelegt
neben dran
[Musik]
natürlich einen teelöffel voll wertvoll
und gibt einfach in die mitte wo frei
dann vorsichtig
[Musik]
ich weiß die uhr helfern und wirklich
gut drauf und tritt verfolgte fest falls
nötig auch mit drücke ich noch mit einem
kleinen laptop steht also nichts im weg
steht hier diese löcher ein erstes mal
wird dann der teig schon fest alles
läuft nicht auseinander
und ich habe auch nur mit einer dicken
steuer drauf
[Musik]
die minifeuerwehr mit mit einer mischung
aus einem eigelb und zwei esslöffel
wasser bestritten
so bekommen sie einen richtig schönen
glanz und ich kann noch so kleine
herzlich schon ein kredit
[Musik]
so kommen wären vorgeheizten backofen
bei 190 grad ober unterhitze etwa 20 25
000 ich finde schöne bräune haben wenn
ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr auch das
kleine holzteile reinstecken
dann kann man es auch auf der hand essen
erhalten sie pop punk dafür steckt hier
hinein in die marmeladen füllung dann
kommt der slogan dazu platzieren dass
man den stehen dann ist sie und dann
wird uns fest drücken
[Musik]
robert pattinson ich hatte auch
abführung machen und ich find's ganz
wenig vorzuwerfen teilte dann bis in den
herbst
ich suche jetzt einfach den schönsten
raus am stiel oder ohne am schlusskurs
und ihr könnt jetzt den interessen oder
fordern jetzt habe ich natürlich ein
bisschen zu viel aber das zurück
equipment ist und genau so oder so
richtig saftig also richtig lecker
durch die entlastung freuen uns sehr
lecker und falls ihr noch zeit übrig
habt also ich hab ich noch aufgehoben da
macht man einfach so einen großen strauß
saison wenig super super meter kostet
aber ich finde sie sehr gelungen solche
aufgegeben
und falls ihr jetzt auch die justiz nach
machen wollt dann geht auch fest lockte
eben doch dem noch mal alle und ich bin
ich sehr schön bei verstopfter straßen
kann man auch mit fleisch machen ist mir
ja kann man machen
der ortsteil war sogar mit fleisch also
es war immer man hat diesen preis
gemacht und selber praktisch nur die
kruste für das innere ihnen war dann im
saftigen fleisch füllung von beispiel
oder hinten drin gemacht und derzeit auf
dem boden mit gegessen
mittlerweile ist es einfach nur doch man
öfter er im süßen heimatstadt mein herz
fassen indem zeigt natürlich mit israel
das beste daran oder kann ich nur mal so
kann es normalerweise habe ich geb dir
einfach so mit und ihr dürft euch gerne
schriftliche regelung anschauen
[Musik]